I'm gonna buy my own drinks kind of
evidence
we all have our lines mine is at the bar
like I want equal pay in a Chardonnay in
a clip from her new HBO special nice
lady the comedian has grabbed the
spotlight through her success and stand
up and her regular role on the daily
show and tonight she takes the stage at
one of Washington DC's biggest events of
the year Jamie wax is here with more
Jamie good morning good morning Anthony
Michelle wolf will be hosting the White
House Correspondents Association dinner
an event that draws big names in
politics journalism and entertainment of
course and we talked to her about her
career her competitive edge and
tonight's gig including the fact that
the guest of honor
won't be in the room
[Applause]
[Music]
I wanted to be so shrill that if I suck
the helium out of a balloon it wouldn't
change my voice at all that might be a
hundred percent real thing that happened
to me Michelle wolf has created a
fast-rising career for herself by being
a standout stand-up show wolf everybody
whether it's talk show appearances slots
at high-profile charity events to touch
a boo or her currently streaming HBO
special nice lady baby you should have
to take a tester to something simple
like let me see your iPhone screen
oh it's Cranston no wolf has been
consistently singled out for the quality
of her comedic craftsmanship a lot of
times you feel like a comedians just
doing five minutes from their act on a
talk show or on a variety evening but
you really work on crafting that as its
own piece yeah I mean I think it's
important to have like to feel like
people are seeing like even if it's just
five minutes like a little show you know
or you're just like no I did this for
you it wasn't just a small collection of
jokes it was like no I made you a little
thing I made you a meal the current meal
she's taking on is one of the toughest
and most prestigious gigs in comedy
hosting tonight's White House
Correspondents Dinner joining a long
list of respected comedians the biggest
thing everyone says which you know is a
stand-up going into it is it's a bad
room it's a big ballroom there's
circular tables which is bad for comedy
because some people aren't looking at
you it's during dinner which is bad for
comedy because they're focused on eating
or not eating or drinking as much as she
seems like a natural comedian humor
wasn't always an obvious gift on full
display though was her determined and
competitive nature like in college I
didn't
want to just get an AI want to get the
best grade in the class because you know
how like your grades are listed by like
your social security number or whatever
I always wanted to be the top like I
always wanted the best grade
I mean it's insanely competitive for no
reason at first that drive for the top
landed her a job in the world of finance
not comedy at first I was like yeah I
can do this I'm gonna be a finance
person and then every quickly was like I
hate this this is not my thing at all
and then Bear Stearns collapsed and then
like a week later I started my first
improv class and I just immediately
loved it now why are you wearing
sunglasses inside because the Sun will
come out tomorrow and I just can't even
it didn't take long for Wolf's writing
and persona to catch the eye of two of
today's most influential late-night
shows Late Night with Seth Meyers and
The Daily Show with Trevor Noah
what did you learn from from that kind
of experience out of the club's writing
for someone else with a team well I mean
writing for someone else's voice is very
hard and it's a good skill to learn and
it helps you think from different
perspectives
Trevor taught me a lot about like
performing and like because he's such a
charismatic performer that I learned a
lot of that from him and I learned a lot
from Seth about like just like joke
writing and economy of words and you
know just having like strong punchlines
this is the studio where Colbert was
shot yeah
and now they're building your set what
does that feel like it's crazy cuz
Colbert wasn't like my favorite show
whoof has now poised herself to become
one of only a handful of women breaking
into late-night when Netflix launches
the break with Michelle wolf in late May
I'm not trying to like reinvent the
wheel with this show I'm just trying to
get back to like having just a really
funny show I'm not gonna talk about
policy here you know but for the moment
she remains focused on tonight's event
with or without the presence of the
traditional guest of honor does that
make it better for you as a comedian or
harder for you that the president is not
there would you rather the president be
in the room I mean I like making fun of
people to their face more than anything
like more than behind their back so it
would have been
finally I think to like you know just
I'm I'm none of my jokes changed I guess
it's nicer to make fun of someone when
they're there
I think it's cowardly not to go I think
it's the only other person that didn't
go as Reagan when he was shot and he
called in what are you most concerned
about I guess I just want people to be
like those were funny jokes you know
like I'm not trying to like like make
some sort of bigger point or anything I
just want people to be like it was
really funny
I'll be really happy when it's over yeah
the homework assignment it's really you
want to be the a at the top of the list
and if watching c-span tonight does not
satisfy your desire for Michelle wolf
material her Netflix myth series
premieres on Sunday May 27th it's a
weekly series and another woman in late
nights great great but did you hear a
dare in there I distinctly heard a dare
like mr. Trump that is she is right that
is one it's not a bad room it's a
horrible room yeah I mean for a comedian
because it's huge and and it's in if you
hit if you die in there it's painful
death and to make it worse the broadcast
they usually don't put a mic on the
audience so there's nothing like a
comedian delivering a line and then no
sound while you're watching at home it
will also be on CBS n this evening the
White House correspondent dinner so
you'll see how she how she did